that's it the before this video begins
to have another giveaway excitement yes
from origin PC these have always been
very popular so definitely make sure you
join in this time we're giving away the
Evo 15s gaming laptop look at this
beautiful thing nah a metal angle of
this bad boy feature not yet launched HD
UV textured printing by origin PC so if
you printer a brofist on it you will
feel the brofist take a second and think
about that it's popping out so you can
feel it in all its glory
you can feel the textures of the print
Origin PC promised that they would send
me one you better but to join the
giveaway check out Origin PC comm size
PT PI and you could win one enjoy the
video guys you want to give me for free
doesn't matter how much my fans comes
first and I love them so much especially
when they leave on my see I didn't see
you at all how long has this been
recording did you hear that wasn't even
important just standard conversations I
have today if you didn't guessed it
already we're gonna review the oops
didn't mean to subreddit that's funny in
original Felix did you come up with that
yourself stop being mean stop hating
stop I love everybody alright let's
begin
check out this barbecue sauce I bought a
while back wrong picture that would be
my dick I'm sorry about that here the
correct picture okay
mean to send a picture of my ding-dong
could happen to anyone I mean I always
store my pictures of my barbecue sauce
right next to my pictures of my
ding-dong it's a common thing I'm always
mixed them up except what is kind of
bigger than the others but oopsie
youtubers Logan Paul says he didn't
realize tasers electrocute things did I
just see you again I didn't know I just
what is that things just make an oopsie
some time caught myself trying to figure
out portrait mode this is me puzzled
good night listen up Johnny you're not
fooling anyone this is not an oopsie
this is what I like to call in the UC
community of fake ooh Lucy this man is
lying to you this is a fake over sir and
I'll show him by smashing his face
stupid taking me man me I don't want any
fake absurd now this this is real when
you take a picture by accident this
should be good we're trying to
screenshot something
[Music]
now this all this sub red is going to be
just people posting selfies your nipples
look weird might you might want to check
that out okay
not interested great another one when
you were just trying to show off your
shoes in a picture but people mistake it
for you trying to get dudes in your DMS
without having to actually say it Wow I
don't know why maybe they're asking you
where did you get those her HS let me
just show you guys my socks always
wanted to show you my socks here they
are don't get any any weird ideas
[ __ ] no more selfies please can't you
just admit is it so hard to admit that
you want to share a picture of yourself
what the a this was a total
unintentional photo I took of myself one
of the first ones I ever took with my
new camera it's kind of metaphorical
though I'm in the captain's chair the
driver seats I can set the destination
for my journey and not just this small
journey from one location to another
I'm the captain on my laughs and I can
set my destination this backseat drivers
yes but with practice and determination
I'm learning how to shoot those voices
app even my own voice something that
much can mean hashes but I can't anyway
me dad good bad Dobby am i right just
shared about your thoughts again didn't
even plan that out I was going to
reference Marxism Marxism but then no
one would understand it do it and then
explain it it's so long and nerdy I'd
have to explain the dialectic model
which has the thesis antithesis and
synthesis scenario where the working
class takes over through revolution crap
I did it again
[Music]
spotted hard at work and literally
someone just sent me this photo from an
unknown number I'm creeped out but also
thankful to know that I look elegant
sleeping you told your friend to send
you that picture you rigged the whole
thing they're faking the game they're
faking the social media game this is no
longer an oopsie doops eat
it's a freaky deaky what is his sound
effect with ambience dum it's a demo
sorry I was hacked the number one
defense in the oops I didn't mean to
community is to claim that you've got
somehow hacked and this is really just
someone else that did it not you
dropping my new song Monday if this gets
a hundred thousand retweets thousand
retweets by the way my twitter got
hacked somebody is threatening to
release my ex totally didn't mean to
send me a selfie with her marriage
certificate
oops sorry meant for someone else
Oh crazy you can just click the wrong
picture and then juice everything good
one eating cereal and this happened
completely by chance oh my I didn't even
touch them I swear
see well you gotta appreciate the
aesthetic or whatever not like I had
anything to do with a Jesus beer change
what a [ __ ] I mean truck trying to help
my buddy Sally's f-150 sorry if you
I'm so sorry if you'd wanted to because
that's definitely not what I am
interested in okey I'm just a man trying
to sell a woman a truck here okay you
gay son or at least your mommy's praying
before we shot a video today my camera
went off on a timer would that be
charging or programming it so I thought
that maybe the Lord wanted me to share
that special candid moment this is me
praying with my girlfriend and I did not
set up a camera with a tripod in front
of me oopsie-doopsie you see it just it
was Jesus Christ I took this out for
himself okay you mind if I praise God
hahahahaha
titty Oh what that was not my
girlfriend's Tootsie Tata
well this one is they're just having a
fun I'm gonna let this one slide some
people some of you in the community
might say this is a faker de coeur but
no it's an okay with me video chat soon
I want to get you nakey should have
stopped at the video chat soon I was
about to say yes
oopsie the last part was autocorrect I
was trying to say I want to get you
naked not Nicki you silly goose hey guys
so I accidentally bought a Range Rover
and now my mom is making me salad if
anyone in Toronto wants to buy it please
DME thinks how do you accidentally buy a
car oh oh I just like fell
I literally just fell and then I had the
keys to the car in my hand these things
happen you would understand husband
accidentally you know as soon as someone
writes accidentally in a social posey
then you just call [ __ ] right away
yet perfectly caught one of the best
moments and feelings ever in my lifetime
how can you hate this accent oh I mean
oh god damn it question mark that was an
accident
how did you accidentally
yeah yeah dick no I was just messing
with the camera and my dick happened to
be out I swear haha so random am i right
everybody that was so random just waving
to the crowd yes
that's oh my god I can totally relate to
this whenever I did that it was an oopsy
doopsy to please please please you are
you kidding me YouTube I'm having a hard
time receiving accurate notifications
for my actual subscribed channels and
this crap pops up I never once clicked a
video of his at least try to hide the
favor ISM logan paul is back in
notifications Oh oopsie our bad we fix
it so that only logan subscribers will
get it going forward
do you like anyone yeah you have a
boyfriend yeah you question mark oh
great if you see the like on this video
and share it with all your family and
friends and everyone that you know
oopsie
alright guys hope you enjoyed and I'll
see you guys next time finally done with
this crap stupid idiots are gonna love
this [ __ ]